right here
[Music]
Sarah Sarah
Taylor
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
shut
the hell up shut up
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go beat her
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm done
laughs
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
hi everyone I'm Lil a senior Humanities
major and I am Nico also a senior
Humanities major
and we are going to be your tour guides
for today
thank you thank you it is just it is
just a gorgeous day isn't it Lil that's
right Nico every day at Yale is a
gorgeous day because as we like to say
even if it's raining at least we've got
a 42 billion dollar umbrella
today we are going to show you
everything you need to know to decide if
Yale is right for you and don't worry
we'll finish at the bookstore where you
can buy a 70 sweatshirt you only have a
five percent chance of actually wearing
at the school
heel is so competitive because it only
takes students who will change the world
after graduation five members of my
froco group are on Fast Track to
becoming president oh and my best friend
is zooming in from the International
Space Station
[Music]
oh and Lil why don't you tell them about
your job at the Peace Corps
did I say that I'm pretty sure I said I
was going to work for a values-driven
organization striving to make
revolutionary changes to communities in
need
so what's the job
Goldman oh
are they hiring we'll chat offline
anyway let's Dive Right In with
academics Yale offers almost Limitless
classes we
Advanced stage combat
econ
it's about
lessons are actually useful Lil what's
the most useful class you've ever taken
uh backwards alphabet 302 it's this
class where you memorize the alphabet
backwards in case you're ever pulled
over for drunk driving
so
and Nico what about you oh well I want
to be a comedy writer so the most useful
class I ever took was classical
Hollywood nepotism
Nico's not alone everyone at Yale writes
comedy professors call them essays but
what else do you expect from putting
marks in a conversation with Drake that
class was called God's plan
your curriculars are also huge at Yale
every year the ydn's editor-in-chief
writes for the New York Times the
president of the investment Club works
for Bain and the students from the Yale
Farm tried their hand at real farming
okay I lasted one week okay you thought
cs323 was hard try milking a heifer you
cannot milk a half a remotely oh but you
can attend a spizz Wings concert from
the comfort of your childhood basement
that's right turns out you don't need to
be at Yale to be at Gale over the
pandemic our classmates didn't stop
striving writing albums starting
non-profits going to the Moon
[Music]
Nico on the other hand started dating
his roommate
[Laughter]
and Lil wants a clown School in France
low why don't you give them a little
taste of what you've been wearing no I
don't think we need to come online
come on people get excited for Lil she's
gonna give us some clowns come on come
on
this cost me ten thousand Euro
okay anyway we've been a rambling you
must be burning with questions what can
we answer for you oh right there in
front
yeah hi
um can I just say that this is such a
quaint lawn you guys have like I
actually like love Yale like you guys
have something going for you here it's
pretty like sick honestly really because
uh because you're dressed from head to
toe in Harvard apparel oh
this oh my god I didn't even notice I
just kind of like threw this on this
morning
a question yeah so it's actually a tube
harder number one how tall is your
president
um legally speaking he is over six feet
off the Record
far less
cute adorable really and my second
question is did you guys even apply to
Harvard
I mean it was what I really remember it
was a long time ago it was really the
right school for me in the end so I
thought
did you get in
I did
I did not get into Harvard
me neither
no more questions I just hope that
endowment keeps you satisfied she gets
it nope okay
wait
he's right I'm a failure I shouldn't
even be up here today Lil don't listen
to that guy they don't even have a cute
mascot
no
I'm serious
if I were in Cambridge right now I would
have nothing to worry about well I
Yale is an amazing school I mean how you
met me your best friend
one of your best friends
well a friend yeah but you made a friend
I mean that's huge how else could I
convince you that Yale is the right
choice
[Music]
what is that that's the Yale fight song
but that can only mean one thing
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God
thank you
or saw this thing
is that you the ghost of eliu Yale
oh lovely day isn't it
speech is a bit long but uh I'm here to
wrap things up Mr Yale what a pleasure
and your accent is so period appropriate
oh my God a little buddy you told me use
was graduating congratulations
uh Mr Yale I mean we don't really feel
like celebrating
four years what have we even
accomplished
Mr Downey
she could have got Skull and Bones I
you took that happiness class but you're
still right depressed are you
she's very happy actually very happy
oh so what's the problem then love well
to be honest Mr Yale I mean today is
supposed to be a celebration but
where have I even gained here and where
am I even going
ah I can understand that I used to be an
officer in the British Navy
everything at Sea can change in the
blink of an eye the wind the waves the
Sharks laughing at your hair
but when you've got your crew you can
make it through rough wars
okay so am I the boat and life is the
water I'm the water it's a nautical fall
didn't you learn anything at this place
okay well that's why I'm insecure about
Mr Yale oh it is
one day I wrote In Me Dory
it's not about where you're sailing to
but ooh you're sailing with
and I live by those words
didn't you die at sea
we'll check I'll fly love
okay thank you Mr Yale that was kind of
helpful oh it must be your thing you
want to get back to me free on review
reunion
I'm going as he's on a Maurice cup with
Nathan Hale
hi Mr Yale wow great guys
very Progressive that's sweet that he
and Nathan are still friends
maybe you and I will still be friends
after 300 years
maybe
I've been so caught up trying to figure
out how to live up to this yeah Legacy
that I've forgotten I'm surrounded by
the best crew on the Eastern Seaboard
you all
always here to lift the mass when I'm
weak steer the ship when waters are
rough swab the deck after night at
Luther
wait what
like
it's the friends you made along the way
but this is supposed to be our tour
group oh right
welcome to the Yale bookstore
sweatshirts are inside good luck and
thank you for visiting
[Applause]
[Music]
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
class day
[Applause]
my name is and this past year I have had
the absolute honor and privilege of
serving as the Director of strategy and
Communications for class day 2023
Yale College Class Day originated in the
19th century when the entire graduating
class at that time fewer than 100
students gathered in a circle on Old
campus to share memories of their time
at Yale
although the ceremony has now clearly
grown in size its Central tenets of
cherishing our time at Yale celebrating
the accomplishments of our classmates
and Reminiscing on the memories we've
made all continue to hold true
class day is brought to you by the class
Day committee LED under the incredible
direction of Professor Allison Coleman
director of Special Projects whose
leadership this event simply would not
be possible without
throughout the ceremony you'll hear from
my fellow members of the committee as
zipporah will introduce our class day
speaker yabi and Anastasia will discuss
the traditions of class day and Ada and
Siad will introduce ways of capturing
our time at Yale
through this we hope you will get a
glimpse of the depth and breadth of the
Yale class of 2023.
and as you join us in commemorating the
class of 2023 I hope you'll also honor
yourselves as the families friends and
loved ones who have so greatly
contributed to where we stand today
class day is a celebration of all of us
now I'd like to turn it over to Sephora
to introduce our class day speaker
[Applause]
thank you
thank you Bayonne I'm zipporah class
Anthology editor
[Music]
be sure to read it too
and I have the wonderful honor of
introducing our speaker Elizabeth
Alexander
Elizabeth Alexander is a decorated poet
educator memoirist scholar and cultural
Advocate she is the president of the
Mellon Foundation the nation's largest
funder in arts and culture and
Humanities in higher education
over the course of a distinguished
career in education Dr Alexander has
taught and inspired a generation of
students including at her alma mater yo
University as chair of the African
American studies department and the
inaugural Frederick Eismann professor of
poetry in 2015.
among her many accolades include the
Jackson poetry prize the John Simon
Guggenheim Memorial Foundation
Fellowship the George Kent award the
National Endowment for the Arts
fellowship and three pushcart prizes for
poetry please help me welcome Elizabeth
Alexander
[Applause]
thank you
hello everybody
it is wonderful to see you all today
there are lots of us
I am tremendously honored to have been
chosen to be your class day speaker and
I would like first to thank president
salave Dean Lewis
the members of the class Day committee
who I had the wonderful chance to get to
know before coming to today
the countless and tireless organizers of
Yale's commencement weekend ceremonies
the members of the Board of Trustees who
have joined us today the heads and deans
of Yale College the members of the
senior class Council
The Faculty staff parents siblings
aunties uncles cousins friends and
alumni in attendance
and of course the Glorious members of
the class of 2023.
we are so proud of you
and we are here to honor your many
achievements at Yale to recognize this
Milestone that you've reached and to
celebrate you as a class as you mark
your time together as Yale students
I've had the vantage point of four
Decades of reflection since I graduated
from here as a Yale senior in the class
of 1984. there was at least there are at
least two of my classmates here Yale
okay wavy wavy I see class of 1984.
I work now in philanthropy but along
that road from graduation I've done a
lot of different things and I became a
tenured Yale faculty member which I'm so
proud of so I come to you though I'm
doing different work now always as a
teacher
I became a poet so I come to you with
belief in the power of the word
my cherished sons who are here today
graduated in the Yale classes of 2020
and 2021 which as you can figure means
that mother didn't get graduation so
here we all are today and I come to you
so importantly as a Yale mom
I live and work in New York now but in
the math of my life I've lived longer in
this city than anywhere else for almost
20 years so I come to you as a new
Havener proud citizen of this city that
I love
when whenever I return whenever I return
to New Haven if it's springtime I know
exactly how sweet and soft the air will
be
I know which trees will be Lush and In
Bloom and I know the sounds that we will
hear throughout Yale's campus sounds of
particular bird song that I've missed
other places
and the countless chatterings of people
saying goodbye for the summer or for the
Unseen future
I learned more as a Yale undergraduate
than I could possibly recount
how to row six seat in a shell
how to dance salsa and merengue
how to read text closely until meanings
and pattern and Nuance came into clarity
how to work harder than I ever imagined
and have more fun than I ever dreamed of
from crew I learned to try things I'd
never done before
in that sometimes precarious boat I
learned that without shared Mission and
communication the boat can stop dead in
the water
from literary study I learned that
complexity and contradiction can be
understood simultaneously through clear
language and that The Human Experience
can be lived in infinitely different
ways
I learned that hard work can yield
tremendous results
and that when you learn your friends
dances you share culture and connect in
joy
you have to dance
when I graduated from this University I
never supposed that I would come back to
live here and when I did return as a
faculty member and then a department
chair I had the privilege of teaching
and learning with Yale students and
colleagues for 15 years
I believe classrooms are sacred spaces
where we wrestle together with difficult
things
where we learn through argument and in
the case of arts and culture where we
behold with Wonder the power and Beauty
with which artists show us who we humans
are
for 13 weeks a semester we are together
in community and year after year I saw
the revelations that can happen in the
commitment of that shared work and
purpose
the classroom for me is a hive of
intensity and love
for each other and for the work at hand
and I have experienced that love and
connection to endure whenever I see or
hear from former students
all of these remarkable things that have
fundamentally shaped me happened here at
Yale and in New Haven
and New Haven will always be my home
over in that direction toward East Rock
is where I lived and raised my children
in the most beautiful neighborhood in
the most beautiful house with a magic
garden with a magnolia tree with the
scientific name Magnolia accumulata
Elizabeth that my late husband planted
as a gift
over there on College Street is where my
husband and his brothers had his
restaurant the legendary Cafe adulis
where generations of Yale and New Haven
folks were introduced to food from the
Horn of Africa and enjoyed dishes with
Jazzy names like shrimp Barka and two
tomato gig
and just right over there through Phelps
gate is the Civic heart of New Haven
itself City Hall the public library the
New Haven green where so much Community
Gathering and building has happened over
the centuries
it was on the New Haven green that
Center Church in the early 1700s began
holding the commencement exercises for
Yale students before we came here to the
old campus
throughout 1839 and 1840 it was on the
green that a group of Africans from what
was then called mendeland captives from
the slave ship Amistad were let out for
daily exercise during the trial that
would ultimately win them their
emancipation
I picture that
the New Haven green is a common land as
first called by the city's founders
then as now in the ideal it is a space
of encounter and empathy
today I want to tell you a story about
something that happened in a close by
New Haven Neighborhood about 200 years
ago
some of you may know this story but I
believe that many of you are hearing it
for the first time I first learned of it
from two extraordinary members of this
Yale Community my friends Michael morand
at the beinecke and Professor David
blight
I then learned more through research and
through a wonderful documentary called
what could have been made by a born and
raised new Havener who works at the
beinecke Tobias Cropper
the story tells of a wild and beautiful
idea presented in this city on September
7th 1831. that was the day a proposal
for a black college was announced to the
broader public of New Haven
this dream which was the vision of black
and white abolitionists
would have been the first black college
in the United States
imagine for a moment this dream of
Freedom made real
decades before slavery would end in this
country and a century and a half before
Yale enrolled significant numbers of
students of color significant numbers
and before any of the other great hbcus
that are a part of the landscape of
American higher education today had been
built this college would have stood on
Wallace and Water Street a stone's throw
from where we are now
the plan was for a 20-acre campus
a main building had been identified and
secure and the college would have
offered a wide-ranging Innovative
curriculum one grounded in classical
Agricultural and Mechanical instruction
it would have been led by design by
integrated leadership and funded by
subscribers up and down the Eastern
seaboard a truly Visionary idea
carefully planned and ready for
execution
but to the vast majority of white
land-owning new haveners who governed
the town in 1831 the black college was
not seen as a proposal for possibility
and progress and The Liberation that
comes from learning or the Limitless
opportunities that lie at the heart of
Education
in town meetings discussing the matter
participants said the black college was
quote incompatible with prosperity if
not the existence of the present
institutions of learning
they derided the idea of black students
interacting with Yale students in all of
the pride they said of supposed equality
they said the college was destructive of
the best interests of the city
and So within days of the college
announcement New Haven's mayor a Yale
graduate organized in opposition on the
Green
at City Hall New Haven's white
townspeople quickly gathered the leading
voices of whom were also Yale graduates
and together they voted
to reject the black college
the vote was a resounding 700 to 4.
and that was that
now I am a literary scholar my teaching
and scholarship pres and present work
always exist within a deep understanding
of history and historical research
illuminates and feeds much of my poetry
and as I have learned since I was a Yale
student myself the beauty of the study
of history is we find the truth hiding
in plain sight
it provides revelation
the truth is in court records it's in
the census it's in the way we've marked
the land it's in the stories our elders
carry and in records of community
meetings
the story of the black college has
always been there but it has only
recently become more known and explored
right here on this campus as it should
be
the university is now Reckoning directly
with this story and others evolving as
it must in order to move forward as an
Ever more just and truthful Institution
history enables us to ask better and
more informed questions and so I asked
today what might have happened if that
dream of the black college had come to
pass in 1831
how would it have transformed this
community not just intellectually but
spatially
today where we see the intersection of
91 and 95 we would see the college and
imagine today A New Haven with a vibrant
and easily reachable Waterfront where
that college had welcomed students for
two centuries
imagine the black College's educated and
empowered leaders standing alongside
yales and new Havens for generations for
200 years building and enriching this
great City
we can Envision and explore the
possibilities
and we can understand what was lost
remember though higher education was
once nearly imaginable for so many
Americans
they did imagine it
women imagined it
people who were not wealthy or white
imagined it
people who were immigrating to the
United States imagined it before it was
available to them all across the land as
the 19th and 20th and 21st centuries
progressed those many different dreams
of Freedom began to Blossom
all those many institutions land grant
universities women's colleges that were
ultimately built to serve the full
American population
all the people who yearned for
empowerment and Enlightenment that deep
knowledge and critical thinking grants
and Yale itself would open its doors
wider and wider to educate more people
I believe the imperative to help Empower
other people through education is still
urgent today
we do not become educated for ourselves
alone
we become educated for others
I believe the dream of freedom for
everyone has still not fully been made
real
the Yale I first came to in 1980 as an
undergraduate only a few years after the
first women had graduated and then as a
professor in 2000 is the place where I
learned to think
where I learned history culture and
interdisciplinary analysis where I
sometimes fought to be taken seriously
and was taken seriously
where I found my voice and where despite
the powerful teachings in Black Culture
that came from my own household to be
shared with whoever would take those
lessons I first learned about the
extraordinary field called African
American studies
and in that field we see questions of
power and freedom and Humanity being
asked and speculated and answered
for so many of the questions that still
are before us today
African-American studies sits at the
heart of understanding this country and
American culture
and its lessons and teachings and
Inspirations are there for everyone
my professional Journey has taken me
from journalists to Professor to scholar
to poet to memoirist and now to
philanthropy and my work leading the
Mellon Foundation
I never expected to go through the
unusual door that is philanthropy when I
sat where you are in 1984.
I did not even know what philanthropy
was
but today I stand at the Helm of the
nation's largest funder of Arts and
Humanities stewarding its considerable
resources and serving as the voice of
its Clarion call to lift up creativity
artistic practice and the humanistic
Tradition at every turn
the Greek root of the word philanthropy
translates to love of humankind
philane meaning to love
anthropos meaning humankind love of
humankind
and so when I look across my
professional Journey ending with love of
humankind I can see that the through
line is no different than that which
animated my teaching in a Yale classroom
the will to share Beauty and
understanding
empathy curiosity
the belief in learning history with open
eyes so we can better understand who we
are and more importantly who we can
become
and the belief that with these tools we
can truly become a more just Society
animated at every turn by the love of
humankind
one of our signature projects is the
melon Monument projects which is Guided
by these same principles
the goal of this project is for our
country's monuments and memorials to
reflect our actual history in the United
States
not mythology not misinter
representation
we are asking questions about power we
are supporting Visionaries in our
communities who are creatively working
to ask and to answer
who is Remembered in public space and
who is not
which histories are deemed important and
which acts and actors are venerated
and most importantly how do we tell the
stories of Who We Are
we support a monument honoring the
hundreds of thousands of people who
passed through Angel Island immigration
station in San Francisco Bay
and the history telling mural panels of
the Great Wall of Los Angeles by the
artist Judy Baca in Los Angeles
and the totem Trail in Juneau Alaska
which with totem poles commemorates the
legacies of the klingit Haida and
simchian peoples
we're supporting public remembrances of
the Rapid City indigenous children in
the Black Hills of South Dakota the
undertold histories of Appalachia and a
museum that tells the stories of the
coal miners in West Virginia
memorials that Mark the protests for
lgbtq rights at Stonewall in New York
City
and a new monument in Newark to Harriet
Tubman whose courage in leading so many
people to literal freedom
is an inspiration to each and every one
of us
all across the country we at melon are
asking everyone to see and to recognize
the expansive and Tangled multi-vocal
and magnificent American story
for my colleagues in me history is not
who was right versus who was wrong
it is instead understanding Humanity in
its many contradictions and its
countless Collective endeavors
You Beautiful graduates have gone to
school at a place where the study of
history is Central to the University's
identity
this great University teaches us we do
not close our eyes to history we reckon
with it
and this great University taught me that
it was imperative that I share with you
today the history of the black college
and the town Where We Gather today and
so from this story I draw a direct line
to our country and what we're dealing
with in 2023
in 2023 if you were enrolled at a public
university in some states the things you
all learned in ethnic studies and gender
studies and other areas of study here
soon could not be taught to you in your
classrooms
right now in the United States books are
being banned at the highest rate since
the American Library Association first
began keeping records
five times as many books were challenged
last year as when you entered Yale in
2019.
right now we're feeling the impact of
these bigger and bigger steps toward
restriction censorship and
disempowerment in education and I must
ask
what exactly
do those who are Banning education fear
is knowledge itself feared
is freedom of Mind feared
is a truly functional
multi-vocal mutually respectful
democracy feared
is an educated populace that can make
meaning of our lives and think
productively about how to make our lives
better for ourselves and for others is
that what makes people keep the freedom
of deep learning from others
I reflect on these questions real
questions not rhetorical questions and I
hear the rallying Cry of Tracy D Hall
The Warrior poet librarian leader of our
nation's American Library Association
when she says as she does repeatedly
free people read freely
so why do we learn at all
we learn so we can grapple with hard
things
we learn to move further toward
illumination
we learn to engage with the indelible
human Spirit imagining ourselves in the
lives of others in other places and
other times
we learn
and we understand that we are not alone
that we are in fact joined by many
different ways that transcend the
particularities of our race our gender
our backgrounds
we learn
because learning
is exhilarating
I have been a poet longer than I've been
a scholar or a professor or a leader in
philanthropy and Yale is also a place
that is always valued poetry and has
always served as a caretaker for its
enduring art its daily craft its careful
analysis and its deep purpose
I believe that poetry is the soul
distilled
it is the highest form of power and
Precision in language
it brings us Enlightenment in its many
forms written recited sung aloud it
brings us inspiration if we think of the
Latin inspirari meaning to breathe into
poetry comes from the bodies of The
Poets into the bodies of others as
breath
poetry is what Adrian Rich called the
dream of a Common Language the shared
understanding we hope to have
so I wonder what is the common language
of a Yale education in all its varied
expressions
and the common objective of the
opportunities you as Yale graduates will
generate for others in the years to come
we poets from time immemorial have tried
and tried and tried to Define freedom
and found it ineffable
Paulie Murray the great jurist Episcopal
priest poet and graduate of Yale law
school who is now I guess you all are
over there immortalized as the namesake
of one of our residential colleges
so here Paulie Murray and here everybody
she Paulie Murray they wrote a couplet
of Freedom that is very very resonant
today
and I imagine that couplet as a response
to those townsmen of New Haven 200 years
ago who voted 700 to 4 to reject the
black college Paulie Murray wrote
always the dream was the same
always the dream was freedom
to gesture again to my work at Mellon
one of my proudest projects is happening
right here in New Haven imagined and led
by the poet memoirist and Yale law
school graduate Dwayne Betts
Dwayne began to understand the true
liberatory power of books through deep
reading and study
in solitary confinement while
incarcerated beginning as a 16 year old
in an adult prison
where he spent eight years
at the age of you students here across
those eight years
someone slid a book of poems under the
door of his solitary cell
and that began his own journey to
becoming a poet and so much more
his project is called Freedom reads
it aims to put 500 book libraries in
every single prison in this over
prisoned country
is a simple idea
a beautiful idea
and a resonant idea for our time
together today it is a dream coming true
the hard work and study you have done
and all you have found in books here at
Yale has expanded your minds and souls
that right must be afforded to everyone
including people who are incarcerated
because
if we deserve
if we here deserve the power the
imagination the historical perspective
the sharpened thinking the other worlds
the empathy the knowledge of books
then so too do people everywhere
and that is something we can do
book by book
idea by idea
Soul by soul
Freedom Dream by Freedom dream
as we come towards conclusion I look
around at you seniors ready to receive
your hard-earned degrees and I see
so much Beauty
and I know a couple of you and I
especially love one of you
so I know who you all are and I in
talking to you all I know who you are
you are beautiful
I See your action and your optimism
your love and your connection to each
other
even as these years at College have no
doubt been challenging even as you have
experienced something few other yalies
have undergone a global pandemic and all
of the challenges it brought to your
lives and your learning
even then I see and feel your lack of
cynicism your rejection of resignation
your refusal to choose to spare over Joy
your life force
and I see a multi-generational community
of your loved ones and they are the
wealth that you class of 2023 also hold
the place you come from and the people
who love you
have shaped you just as much as your
college education
here are just a few final things that I
as the mom of two Yale graduates and the
professor Auntie of countless others
would offer to you as you leave for your
unseen future
no classroom not even a Yale classroom
has taught you everything you need
be an autodidact
push past where your knowledge stops
keep reading keep asking questions keep
seeking out new ideas new experiences
New Perspectives for ever
nurture a sound mind and a sound body
rest to rejuvenate eat well and
helpfully be physically ready for all
that life will call you to
intellectually emotionally and
spiritually
strong communities are shaped most I
Believe by potent useful loving and
well-intentioned challenges from within
I learned that here at Yale in action
speak up and be courageous
even when you are afraid
speak truth to power
take someone with you by which I mean
bring into the room the voices that are
not in the room
and as I always have to offer as the
great poet Gwendolyn Brooks whose poems
taught me so much wrote
conduct your blooming in the noise and
whip of the Whirlwind
there is no quiet
the times will always be challenging
conduct your blooming in the noise and
whip of the Whirlwind
and finally never forget to live fully
and consciously with joy and gratitude
for this gift of life
animated by the superpower of love
class of 2023
we honor you
we celebrate you
and we love you
and before we go and truly celebrate at
all the festivities that have been
planned for you
I Leave You graduates with one question
what will you do
to make the dream of Freedom real for
everyone
I cannot wait to see what you will do
with love congratulations dear members
of the class of 2023. thank you
thank you
thank you Elizabeth Alexander uh for
calling our attention to the promise of
freedom and the dream of freedom and the
promise and dream of Education
and for reminding us of a time in our
history when choices were made that did
not fulfill the promise of freedom and
the promise of education and for
inspiring us to think about how in our
time we should fight to
serve the promise of freedom and the
promise of Education
it is a wonderful speech thank you very
much
and I want to mention to everybody here
that uh Professor Alexander has written
poems about a book of poetry about the
Amistad that covers that that discusses
the people who lived through that
incident 200 years ago right here on the
green that she was mentioning so it's a
it's a lovely uh
a book of poems that you might want to
read to think about the history of New
Haven in relation to some of the themes
of her speech
so I uh now turning from the series to
the slightly less serious uh you know
we're all wearing these funny hats
um
I uh I have a little bit of business
that I have to conduct with you in just
a moment but before I do I'd like to
invite to the state to come up to the
seats in the front row
the following students Adam David Chen
of Timothy Dwight College
[Music]
Michael Chen of Branford College
[Applause]
Aaron dickstein of Saybrook College
[Music]
Ami Junction Dani of Ezra Stiles College
Julia huntarok levko of Brantford
College
[Applause]
of Trumbull College
over on this site Karen Lee of Paulie
Murray college
[Applause]
Diego Miro of Trumbull College
of Trumbull College
annalize Ratner of Silliman College
[Applause]
Dan Williamson of Paulie Murray college
so we need to do a little bit of dress
rehearsal for tomorrow's event so at at
commencement there's going to be a
moment and I'm going to be standing up
here in front of President salave and
I'm going to present him to you so that
you can receive your degrees
so all the students of the class of 2023
pay close attention
the last two sentences of my request to
president salave are going to go like
this they have been recommended by The
Faculty of Yale College and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees remember these degrees okay
so when you hear the words confer upon
them these degrees
that means that you're graduating okay
that's like that's the moment
Okay so
at that point you have to cheer okay
cheer very loudly okay so they have been
recommended by The Faculty of Yale
College this is practice right and
approved by the corporation
I now ask you by your official act to
confer upon them these degrees
now look look look look I know I've only
been your Dean for one of your four
years and you may not feel that you owe
it to me but you know Dean Chun was Dean
your first three years and I saw his
graduating classes they made a lot more
noise than that
so I need you to be noisier than the
class of 2022 if you can imagine what
that was like so try it again
they have been recommended by The
Faculty of Yale College and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them
these degrees
that's that's much better thank you very
much
foreign
[Applause]
good afternoon everyone my name is
Anastasia huffum
and I'm yavi dagafu
and we are members of your class Day
committee we're here to explain some of
Yale's class day Traditions as we
celebrate the class of 2023 this
afternoon
the incredible students speeches you'll
hear today are a big part of class day
tradition in the centuries paths
class day included formal academic
speeches by members of the graduating
class today students will speak during
the ceremony in several short sets of
remarks about their time at Yale some
serious and others like you saw at the
beginning of the ceremony less so
each year the classic committee has the
privilege of selecting student speakers
to highlight the wide spectrum of
student experiences here at Yale we're
honored to have had that opportunity and
we hope that you enjoy the Gratitude
vulnerability and humor that Lil
[Music]
today's ceremony
another tradition is the creation of the
class Anthology which is a poora who
introduced our class day speaker earlier
compiled and edited
[Music]
the Anthology features Reflections
artwork and poetry from members of our
class that capture our shared Yale
experience you can find a copy of the
Anthology in your class day bags which
also include a handkerchief Yale College
pen and other Keepsake materials we hope
you will take the time to read through
the Anthology and reflect on your time
here
in your class Day gift bags you'll also
find a clay pipe called The Church
Warden pipe which is a tradition dating
back to the 1800s back then graduating
students would sit in a circle and smoke
tobacco from these pipes they would they
would then break the pipes as a signal
that the pleasures of college life have
ended and they would horn they would
hold each other by their hands and Say
Goodbye
times have changed now and the pipes are
simply a memorial of this tradition and
you're welcome to keep them as a
Keepsake or break them your bags will
also include Bubbles as you say your
goodbyes over the upcoming days we hope
that the bubbles will spark some Joy
at the end of today's ceremony we will
sing Bright college Years the song was
written in 1881 by Henry Durand and has
been Yale's unofficial alma mater ever
since sung at reunions football games
and class day on the last lines of the
song we raise our handkerchiefs if you
lost yours from first year or never got
one in the first place the Yale Alumni
Association has generously provided new
ones we'll Rave them as greeters of
graduating classes have done before us
for God for country and for Yale
finally another tradition of class day
is the tradition of planting the class
Ivy which began in 1852 when the first
spine was placed near what is now the
dwalls of Dwight Memorial Chapel the
ivys are symbolic way of our class the
plants its roots before leaving campus
alongside the planting of the ivies it
is tradition for the numerals of each
graduating class to be engraved on this
on a stone on Old campus the numerals
2023 will be engraved on the outside of
Phelps gate this summer leaving forever
leaving a mark of our class on Yale's
campus
over Yale's 322 year History A lot has
changed the ailees of today don't look
like the yales of the 18th century but
the churchwarden pipe and the planting
of the Ivy and class day speakers are
Traditions that unite generations of
Yale graduates all of these class day
Traditions some more silly and some more
serious link our class of 2023 to the
321 classes before us as we move for
being undergraduates to alumni of the
university all of us on the class Day
committee are so grateful to have helped
our class carry on these traditions
thank you everyone and congratulations
[Applause]
well Ami Gan chandani and Dan Williamson
please come to the stage
I am thrilled to announce that the Nelly
P Elliott and William Neely Mallory
awards for the senior woman and man
whose excellence in the field of
Athletics and in their life at Yale best
represent the highest ideals of
sportsmanship and yield tradition go
this year to the two walking up here
Army
Army is one of the greatest Yale women
golfers of all time
[Applause]
in a sport where lower scores are better
she has the lowest scoring average of
any woman yell golfer ever
she also has the lowest career scoring
average of any yell woman golfer ever
she also holds the 18 hole in 54 whole
Yale Women's Golf scoring record and as
an undergraduate she has been an elite
enough golfer to play in the U.S Women's
Amateur Golf Tournament three times in
2019 2020 and 2021.
but that's not all
while dueling all of this she earned a
3.5 grade average in statistics and data
science graduating with distinction in
the major and received the Francis
Gordon Brown Prize last fall all while
being the first Yale student to be the
vice chair of the NCAA division one
student athlete advisory committee her
coach calls her one of the hardest
working individuals she has ever met a
creative Problem Solver and her team's
biggest cheerleader for representing
tremendous athletic accomplishment on
the field and for being everything that
a Yale student athlete should be off the
field Yale takes pride in awarding the
Nellie P Elliott award to Ami gan
chandani
Dan stands out in a Collegiate rowing
program that is one of the best if not
best in the nation
an Olympic competitor in the summer 2021
games who returned to Yale with a gold
medal that marked him
that marked him as one of the most elite
rowers in the world he nevertheless has
given his very best to his college
he was the first year oarsman at Yale
ever to sit in the stroke seat of the
winning Varsity eight
he was a member of the 2019 and 2022 Ira
National Championship crew and in the
years in between covid canceled Yale's
rowing season
an astronomy major with a 3.39 average
his athletic achievement has been called
by his coach who was one of the greatest
roaring coaches of all time close to
incomprehensible
for his tremendous athletic
accomplishment on one of the greatest
Yale rowing teams of all time his
Relentless hard work and his Excellence
as a person and a teammate on a team
that requires that every man to pull
hard at the Oar Yale takes great pride
in awarding the William Neely Manley
award to Dan Williamson
[Applause]
friends families faculty Deans and
graduating students
I'm sure you're all wondering why I
gathered you here today
in all honesty I almost can't believe
that we're here this Monumental day is
one that we've been looking forward to
for the last four years or four plus one
years but in many ways for our entire
lives
when I first came to Yale I was
extremely conscious of monumental days
I believe that college would be the most
important time in my life not just
because of the things I would learn here
but because my college memories would be
somehow more important than all of my
other ones
being the anxious first year I was I
decided I had to consciously remember
everything
every moment was one I was scared to
forget in case it was one I'd want to
remember later in a story that begins
well at my small liberal arts college in
southern Connecticut
of course I was doomed I remember not
enjoying the first year holiday dinner
or not wanting to leave Ben Franklin at
two in the morning to go to a party and
worrying that I was wasting moments that
were supposed to become core memories
these days looked the most like ones I
thought College was supposed to look
like they must have been the bright
College days I'd come to Yale for
as the poet Rowan Ricardo Phillips tells
us though there is no reason to believe
or not to believe what you are seeing
when you see it
one of my closest friends here says that
we met at Bulldog days
he says that we we sat as high school
seniors in the Berkeley dining hall for
over an hour talking about our high
schools our lives and our hopes for the
next four years
I don't remember that lunch
or where I think I met him instead when
he tells that story all I can say is I
don't know where you came from you've
just always been here
that sounds really nice when I say it
but you should know he hates that I
don't remember meeting him
in a way though that's my point
at what became the end of my first year
some people whose Suites had all failed
for one reason or another formed a
living group based on the principles of
respect and communication
when four of us arrived on campus the
following January we discovered that
we'd be living on a floor we had all to
ourselves strictly forbidden by the
coveted guidelines from talking to
anyone else in person
I can't tell you when those casual
acquaintances of mine became people I
would live and die for
it might have been during the third hour
of our Mario Kart tournament or in the
12th consecutive hour of our Mario Kart
tournament
we came up with a saying the four of us
have lived by for the last three years
it's not that college kids are stupid
it's just that we're willing to try
solutions that other people wouldn't
those Solutions have ranged from opening
a can of pineapple with a screwdriver
hanging a birthday pinata from a command
hook
or on the first day we live together
trying to Bunk a bed ourselves a process
which involved me and my now best friend
than a near stranger picking up my bed
and dropping it on the floor until it
split into three even pieces
there are hundreds of stories like those
every single person at Yale is both the
smartest person I have ever met and the
absolute dumbest person in the world
I wouldn't have it any other way
especially because as I think back on my
time here these are the moments that
mean the most to me
there are things each of you has chosen
to do that I don't understand and
probably never will econ Majors how you
doing
but you have chosen to spend your time
and energy on them nothing in this world
matters inherently things matter because
we choose to care about them
I know so many of you have spent the
last few years caring about capital I
important things
from looking for climate solutions to
preserving the languages and traditions
of colonized cultures to writing your
first film scripts or reducing
educational inequities or translating
great works of literature
I on the other hand drank six cups of
coffee one night as my friends and I
worked to produce an entire issue of the
Yale record in 24 hours
I do hope to remember today is one of
the most important days of my life
when I look back on this weekend I want
to think of it as a moment when so many
of the most important people in my life
came together to celebrate the hardest I
have ever worked to get a printed piece
of paper
but if we've seen anything in our time
at Yale it's that nothing is predictable
you will think you're saying goodbye to
a friend for two weeks and not see them
again for months you will see signs
telling you to wash your hands only to
find out that there aren't paper towels
in the bathrooms
you will think of yourself as a good and
honest person until the candy bar you
stole from the Bow Wow makes you wonder
what other atrocities you are capable of
the days that change everything in our
lives are hardly ever the days that look
like they will
so as we move into the next phase of Our
Lives let's hold fast to the lessons we
have learned at Yale
there is no right way to do most things
we are all trying our best
the times we'll remember most fondly
will be the ones we spent looking for
Creative Solutions we don't have the
tools to solve yet
now and forever class of 2023 look for
those problems look for people to solve
them with and look for the fifth most
obvious tools you could use for them
well done everybody you made it here
[Applause]
[Music]
and Karen Lee will you please come up to
the stage
[Music]
thank you
the nakash Nishi prize is awarded to two
graduating seniors who while maintaining
High academic achievement have provided
exemplary leadership in enhancing race
or ethnic relations at Yale College
this year's prizes are awarded to
suzmina Khan of Trumbull college and
Karen
[Applause]
and currently of Paulie Murray college
[Music]
[Applause]
has been a powerful force for community
on and beyond our campus
a political chair then president of the
Muslim Students Association
she has created Interfaith Partnerships
and service projects
for the Yale and New Haven communities
she has also promoted Social Justice by
Building Bridges among student
organizations bringing them together on
phone Banks vigils and fundraisers in
the wake of the murders of George Floyd
and Brianna Taylor
a global Affairs major graduating
laude
shuzmina's view of the community extends
past the bounds of Yale campus
as the executive director of Yale's
international relations Association
she has devoted herself to Refugee
population
cultural Coalition building and
marginalized communities
organized the first ever Yale for
Afghanistan fundraiser
then worked with New Haven Community
groups to help with local refugee
resettlement
she has also created events to raise
awareness of Wego genocide and to
support the Ukrainian people
friends and nominators describe shuzmina
as an activist with a keen desire to
engage with issues of Human Rights and
human dignity
through education and advocacy
she facilitates spaces where students
can learn and engage with contemporary
challenges
for her extraordinary service and
Leadership Yale College is honored to
award the nakanishi prize to shushmina
Khan
foreign
Lee has committed herself to fostering
community
a joyful volunteer and a fierce advocate
for low-income and first-generation
students
she has served as co-president for
Yale's Quest Bridge chapter and his fgli
advocacy movement
Karen is an ethnicity race and migration
major who has made meaningful
connections between her studies and her
commitment to community
she served as a facilitator for the
inaugural cohort of Coalition of
allianship advocates
for the University's office of student
life an organization that provides Yale
college students with access to Dei
training and programs
together with other students she has
developed workshops on Race power and
privilege with the goal of creating an
inclusive environment at Yale and Beyond
Karen has also served as a staff member
for the Asian American Cultural Center
where she facilitated retreats
ongoing programming and special events
like the 40th aacc's anniversary event
Karen's peers know her as a positive and
powerful force for building community
and for fostering inclusivity and
belonging
just as important they praise her for
promoting Racial equality as a lifelong
effort that calls for consistent care
betterment and thought
for her leadership and her commitment to
community Yale College is honored to
award the nakanishi prize to Karen Lee
[Applause]
would you
come to this stage
[Applause]
the James Andrew Hass prize is awarded
annually to that member of the senior
class in Yale College whose breadth of
intellectual achievement strength of
character and fundamental Humanity shall
be adjudged by The Faculty who have
provided leadership for his or her
fellow students
inspiring in them a love of learning and
concern for others
this year the house prize has been
awarded to Julia Hunter lefko of
Branford College
[Applause]
I have to embarrass you first
Julia Hunter roklefko graduates
laude with distinction in her major
sociology intensive
dedicated to gender equity and human
rights Julia has combined her academic
Pursuits with a rich record of service
she has served as initial undergraduate
director of the Lowenstein international
human rights project at the law school
as a European studies undergraduate
fellow at the MacMillan Center
and as a policy intern with the City of
New Haven
earlier this year
she was the recipient of the Roosevelt L
Thompson prize awarded by the Council of
heads of college for service to the
college and the community
Julius commitment to inclusion has left
its mark
as head Aid in the Brantford College
office
she has been integral to our community's
recovery from the pandemic
as part of matriculate at Yale she has
supported students around the U.S to
apply to college
developing Remote programming for
underserved communities
in her leadership to the Yale Slavic
chorus she has uplifted the voice of a
diverse groups of students on and off
the stage
she has been a tireless advocate for
those affected by the war in Ukraine and
an educator on the conflict's most
pressing questions
for her outstanding academic
achievements
and her impressive record of Public
Service
Yale College is proud to bestow the
James Andrew House Memorial prize upon
Julia Hunter roklefko
[Applause]
[Music]
I was born into a burning house when my
mother turned 23 she had an arranged
marriage with my father a ganglord in
Bali India during the years she was
married she was starved beaten and
locked in the house for days on end
when she escaped my father and his
soldiers hunted my mother and me and we
were faced with two options
leave or die
my mom her parents and I sought refuge
in America with one hundred dollars and
two suitcases among the four of us
I grew up in Kentucky as a queer
immigrant Greek Orthodox Christian in a
single parent household subsisting on
free school lunches and Welfare
for much in my childhood I was tormented
for my intersecting identities
on this auspicious day
I can't help but wonder how ten-year-old
Abby who came home from school crying
every day because she was bullied so
relentlessly
would think of me today
I think he would be proud
that we
[Applause]
that we grew up to be more than what
people told us we could be achieving
more than what people told us we could
and living a life that people told us
was impossible
I believe many of us feel the same way
that our childhood selves would be proud
of the people that we become
smart
kind passionate and of course
debilitatingly good looking
I would not have been able to accomplish
any of this in my because my family and
I received love and support from friends
family and strangers
my mother wouldn't have been able to
escape her marriage if it wasn't for a
neighbor who fed her and was able to
recover her nursing certificate for the
doctor at the hospital my mom first
worked at who co-signed for a first car
for the teachers that believed in me
when I didn't even believe in myself
thank you Miss medley Miss Williams and
Mr Purvis and for the friends I made
along the way that I couldn't imagine my
life without thank you Mira Taylor
kenzem Tina Elizabeth Matt my society
Griffin and countless others I could
write entire speeches about
as a society we have and glorified this
notion of being self-made of achieving
success by one's own efforts alone
this very concept is a distortion of
reality
the idea of being self-made perpetuates
the myth of pulling yourself up by your
bootstraps
this is not to say that you didn't work
hard there's not even to say that you
don't deserve the success you have or
will achieve
this myth and this notion erases the
fact that we never go through this life
alone and that we do not leave this
earth without a few scars
have the courage and humility to admit
that you are not self-made
we are forged in a Heart of Love by our
friends family and strangers it is vital
we remember this as we take our first
steps out into the world
and out of the Yale bubble
how will you pay it forward
we are told from a young age that we can
accomplish anything we set our minds to
we look to Heroes for the people that we
could become
Superman and his strength Spider-Man and
his Integrity Bill Clinton and his
luscious Lots
we think we can save the world
but the world has changed a lot since we
were kids
today our globe and our nation are
increasingly embroiled in chaos Division
and violence
it's easy to lose hope for a better
tomorrow
it's even easier to delude yourself into
thinking that nothing you do or ever
will do will make a difference in a
world so big with even bigger problems
I too have been discouraged
I find comfort in a verse from the
talmud whoever saves One Life Saves the
World entire
my Allah saved my life
who will you save to save the world
I look out into this crowd and I have no
doubt that I see greatness among you
but being good is harder
it requires sacrifice putting others
before yourself and an abundance of love
we're inundated around campus with our
historic motto Lux at Veritas light and
Truth
it's difficult though sometimes to
ground these lofty abstract ideals
how do we apply them to our lives
the truth is the truth is your armor and
the light will illuminate the path that
you must take
but it is love that gives us the will to
persist to persevere to prosper
love is not merely a noun but it is a
powerful action
for 22 years two-thirds so my mom and
I's names belong to a man that was not a
part of our lives
this past summer we changed our names to
honor the love that God showed to a
single mom and her child as they sought
refuge in America
together we are creating a new Legacy
based on the most important thing
love
the practice of Love isn't perfect
though we will trip falter and fail we
must ask for mercy and forgiveness just
as often as we give it
and we must practice love every day
do not start tomorrow
start today and love every day
I challenge you to perform one random
act of kindness each day
whether it's buying a stranger a meal
being a good friend or even caring to
hold the door open for an extra 15
seconds
Love is Easy just as long as we let it
be
we must continue to keep the hope for a
better tomorrow
but hope without action is aimless
love is that action love sustains hope
love drowns hate love is our greatest
act of resistance it transcends race
class and Creed
I was born into a burning house but we
were born into a burning world
my ummah and I found Hope through the
power of love
and together class of 2023 we can too
refusing to add to the Flames is not
enough but it is the courage to build a
more loving world that saves us
who will you love today
thank you
[Applause]
thank you Abby for those truly inspiring
words
would Adam David Chen please come to the
stage
[Music]
[Applause]
the Warren Memorial High scholarship
prize is awarded to the senior majoring
in the humanities who ranks highest in
scholarship
this year the prize is awarded to Adam
David Chen of Timothy Dwight College
Adam Chen graduates summa laude with
distinction his major history of Art and
with the degrees of Bachelor of Arts and
master of arts
elected to Phi Beta Kappa after only
four terms of enrollment and the
recipient of this year's wrexham prize
in the humanities
he has completed 43.5 credits with no
grade other than a straight A
foreign
extraordinary student and practitioner
of the Arts and Humanities he has
co-curated an exhibition of 17th century
Dutch art for the Yale University Art
Gallery and Boston's Museum of Fine Arts
and he's also a musician who has been
part of the Guild of caroliners and a
Pianist in the Timothy Dwight College
orchestra
in recognition of his extraordinary
scholarly achievements and the depth of
his intellectual and cultural
commitments Yale College is proud to
award the Warren Memorial High
scholarship prize this year to Adam
David Chen
[Applause]
Aaron dixstein would you please come up
to the stage
the Arthur Twining Hadley prize is
awarded annually to the senior and Yale
College majoring in the social sciences
who ranks highest in scholarship
this year the prize is awarded to Aaron
dickstein of Saybrook College
Aaron Dixon graduates summa laude a
double major with economics and
Mathematics as his first major and
statistics and data science his second
he also graduates with distinction in
economics and Mathematics he was elected
to Phi Beta Kappa in the spring of 2022
his first term of eligibility
and even before then his instructors
have commended him again and again for
performing at the top of his courses
Aaron has also served as an economics
research assistant using data on
academic Publications he's written
scripts to track the success of
doctorate recipients he has been
instrumental in campus organizations
like fed challenge math counts and hack
Yale he's also been a valued presence in
the Yale political union and yihy Yale's
Community Organization for Orthodox
Jewish students and an MVP on the
intramural basketball and chess teams
A Gifted scholar at home in Academia he
is beginning his professional path in
the private sector as a quantitative
researcher in the months ahead in
recognition of his exceptional record
and promise of future success Yale
College proudly confers the Arthur
Twining High scholarship prize this year
upon Aaron Dixie
I believe nin is not present
I will read the uh the uh
citation the Russell Henry Chittenden
prize is awarded annually for the senior
majoring in the Natural Sciences or in
mathematics who ranks highest in
scholarship this year's prize is awarded
to neenuen of Trumbull College
was elected to Phi Beta Kappa in her
junior year and graduate summa laude
with a Bachelor of Science in computer
science and Applied Mathematics with
distinction in her major and with a
master of science in computer science
but distinction applies to her entire
academic record at Yale she has earned
an A in every one of her 45 course
credits
the classroom
me has devoted herself to teaching she
has served as an undergraduate learning
assistant for nine different courses
over three years in the Departments of
mathematics computer science statistics
and data science and economics
and she has also served as a grader for
the mathematics department for three
years and he has also been an active
participant and board member of the
Vietnamese Students Association at Yale
providing leadership as social chair
secretary and co-president she's been on
the events team for the computer science
Society an aspiring Professor Nee will
begin her Graduate Studies at NYU this
fall where she plans to pursue a PhD in
computer science for exceptional
scholarship and future promise in her
field Yale College proudly Awards the
Russell Henry Chittenden prize to need
nuan
Diego Diego
Miro Rivera and Anna Lee
and Annelise Ratner will you please come
up to the stage
[Applause]
the Lewis settler prizes for excellence
in the Performing and creative arts are
awarded to two outstanding seniors
Diego Miro Rivera of Trumbull college
and Annelise Radner of Silliman College
Diego Miro Rivera graduates laude
with distinction in both of his Majors
art and cognitive science
more than a visual artist or even
thinker Seer or doer he is a dreamer who
opens his audience's eyes to new ways of
looking at the world around them
through interventions and installations
designed to change perspectives and
moods and by turns grandiose and subtle
even Sly Diego is acutely aware that he
has the ability to alter the reality we
interact with as we go about our daily
lives
through his art he strives to change the
world one moment of beauty and poetry at
a time
and In The Same Spirit of change Diego
in his unofficial role as mayor of the
art major class of 2023
has also laid the foundation for the
first ever dedicated undergraduate Art
Space providing a much needed outlet for
collaborative work and curatorial
practice
for his ambitious nature his vision and
his gifts for bringing dreams to life
Yale College is delighted to award the
Lewis settler prize for excellence in
the creative arts to Diego Miro Rivera
[Applause]
Annelise Radner graduates summa
laude with distinction in her major film
and media studies
her films are formally inventive
emotionally resonant and deeply
thoughtful and they explore complex
intensely personal subjects with courage
and creativity
a child and grandchild of survivors of
the Cambodian genocide Annelise has used
her artistic practice to excavate and
share the truths of intergenerational
trauma of Greece grief and pardon me of
grief of Grace
that have shaped her
whether using hand-drawn animation to
transform archival news footage into
pointed poetry or light sound and set
dressing to turn a safe Suburban home
into a fraught Fantastical Dreamscape
Annelise creates richly layered works of
Cinema
ambitious and meticulous as a writer and
director annalize is also gifted and
giving as a producer cinematographer and
mentor through her work with Yale
cinematic Productions and her service on
countless student film sets annalize has
invested as much care in the growth of
her fellow students as she has in her
own
for exceptional Talent as a filmmaker
and for her lasting contributions to
Yale's film culture Yale College is
delighted to award the Lewis settler
prize for excellence in the Performing
Arts to Annelise Ratner
[Applause]
president Solomon is actually down there
shaking all the hands and I I believe
he's singing them either Bob Dylan or
the Grateful Dead as he shakes their
hands
of one left anyway Michael Chen will you
please come up to the stage
[Applause]
[Music]
hi Michael
the alpheus Henry snow prize is awarded
to that senior who through the
combination of intellectual achievement
character and personality shall be
adjudged by The Faculty to have done the
most for Yale by inspiring in his or her
classmates an admiration and love for
the best traditions of high scholarship
this year the snow prize is awarded to
Michael Chen of Brantford College
oh
Michael Chen graduates laude with
distinction in his two majors political
science and ethnicity race and migration
elected defy Beta Kappa at commencement
he has also completed the Brady Johnson
program and Grand strategy and an
advanced language certificate in Chinese
a finalist for the Truman roads and
keysby scholarships next year Michael
will pursue a masters in migration
studies at Oxford University as a
marshall scholar
Michael who previously received Yale's
David Everett Chandler award is Guided
by his ethical commitments in his
scholarship and service his senior
thesis which celebrates the efforts of
immigrant communities to secure the Elm
City resident card
was awarded the Richard Hagel prize for
excellence and scholarship about New
Haven
Michael has also served as co-director
of New Haven's integrated Refugee and
Immigration Services census project as a
research assistant for the law school's
Lowenstein human rights project and its
Justice collaboratory and as an intern
with the Legal Aid Society immigration
law unit in New York City
a first generation low-income student
Michael has been a transformative
advocate for the fgli community he was
head recruitment coordinator for Yale
admissions
lead academic strategies Mentor for the
porvo center
peer liaison for the Asian American
Cultural Center
and a first-year counselor for Brantford
his efforts in expanding the Yale and
you program for fgli applicants resulted
in an unprecedented yield for the class
of 2027 which will be the most diverse
in Yale's history
for his remarkable generosity toward
others for all that he has done and in
admiring anticipation of all that he
will do Yale College takes great
pleasure in bestowing the alpheus Henry
snow prize upon Michael Chen
[Applause]
thank you
there we go
I couldn't find my booklet cereal hello
my name is Ada uzenlar
and I'm a member of this year's class
Day committee
the past few weeks I found myself making
mental notes of a new thank you goodbye
card to write after almost every
conversation I had
this lengthening list made me realize
just how many people there are in our
Lives who have worked to get us to this
juncture
in your class Day gift bags you'll find
an envelope with a blank note card
these are intended to give one last
thanks to someone in your life at Yale
who has supported you
they could be a friend faculty staff
family member
they could have driven you the 15-hour
trip to drop you off in New Haven every
single year or just save you a spot in
class
today's celebration is about gratitude
for all of those individuals just as
much as it is about us
in some cases there are people we want
to thank who are no longer with us
this year we lost a fellow student and
friend
Garrett Woodard
I alongside many others here in North
Carolina and elsewhere miss him every
day
and I know that we're not alone
many of us graduating today have
experienced loss during our time at Yale
family members friends and other loved
ones who would have been with us for our
graduation
during periods of Celebration like these
their absence can feel particularly
heavy
but these opposing feelings can and do
exist simultaneously
we can feel proud happy and excited for
the future while also carrying grief and
loss
acknowledging this hurt doesn't gray the
occasion rather it allows us to feel
every other emotion authentically
vibrantly and earnestly
in order to honor loss in a time of
Celebration please join me for a
30-second moment of silence
Garrett is survived by his parents Susan
and Paul
his sister Marilee
and so many other friends and others who
will always love him
the ones we love are memorialized
through their smiles their art
their wisdom
and all of the memories that we have
with them
thank you
[Applause]
hello everyone my name is Ziad Hassan
and this year I had the privilege of
serving as the class history director
for class day
as Ada mentioned our losses remind us of
the critical role memories play in
preserving that which we hold close
what most comes to mind now is the loss
of our status as El students
while some of us may return as graduate
students and others still have a
semester remaining for the majority of
us we will tomorrow lose an identity
that we have cherished for the past four
years
the class history is an effort to
preserve the memories of our time here
a loose recap of the classes time at the
university the video has taken many
forms in the past
but this year emphasis was placed on
incorporating the class itself into the
video as much as possible
we conducted an Outreach campaign to
collect as many videos as possible of
the class of 2023's favorite memories
from their four years at Yale
these span from elaborate organized
musical performances
to the 3am fever dreams that were never
meant to see the light of day
having the class be an integral part of
the video's creation ensure that as many
of our classmates as possible could
reminisce as they look up and watch a
physical preservation of their memories
here
before concluding I would like to remind
the members of the Glee Club to make
their way to the Bandstand while the
history is playing
and without further Ado I present the
class of 2023's History a video by you
[Applause]
[Music]
there we go
now I'm gonna
get told you
[Applause]
[Music]
guys
here we go
[Music]
thank you
that was actually kind of fast
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
all of history can be broken down into
BC and A.D
our class will graduate as the last
class BC with all others graduating A.D
of course the BC and AD I'm referring to
are before covid and after durfees
we are the last class to know Campus
before masks PCR tests and perfection in
the form of a durfy's chicken tender
[Applause]
truly it is the end of an era
When I Was preparing to write this class
Day speech I wanted it to be inspired by
the class of 2023 and to Encompass all
of the aspects of Yale that made our
time at this institution unbelievable
I wanted it to be captivating like the
songs performed by Yale's mini music
groups who made campus feel like a
Disney movie
I wanted it to include humor to
represent the campus groups who spent
their time at Yale trying to make others
laugh
I wanted it to commemorate our time
video or I wanted it to commemorate the
academic grit that uh
commemorate the the wow typo
I wanted it
to commemorate our academic grit there
we go by acknowledging those times in
bass or Sterling or Haas
or beinecke or Taft or LC
or Watson
or wh
IP or Steve
or sci-city
or the ceid
[Music]
or The Buttery
or the dining hall
[Music]
or the Slavic reading room
or our bedrooms
when we felt like we couldn't go on
overwhelmed with life or school but we
persevered so that tomorrow we can walk
across the stage
having blossomed over three or four or
five years into Yale College graduates
most importantly though I wanted this
speech to be like our time at Yale a bit
too short so thank you for your
attention congratulations class of 2023.
[Applause]
and now that we've celebrated 23.5 this
beach
inspired by you two is not quite done
sometimes life like the speech has
unexpected breaks that can teach us the
importance
of friends and companionship
Yale is special because of its people I
encourage you to reflect on your time as
a student and to think about those with
whom you've shared these bright college
Years
remember that time when your first year
Suite mate took care of you after a
night of too much jungle juice at cigno
remember that Tuesday when you were down
in the dumps but had your day brightened
by the warmth and energy of a certain
dining hall staff member
foreign
think about that student who you never
really met but always flashed a smile of
encouragement ahead of a late night
study session during the odd hours of
the morning
find the time to thank them for so much
love before it's too late
as we move forward let us remember our
college Years through the lessons
learned the friendships forged and the
experiences
experienced
let us continue to strive for excellence
to follow our passions and to build
community wherever we go
to our families friends and professors
we extend our deepest gratitude for the
support and guidance you have provided
us along the way
let's stay connected and continue to
support each other no matter where our
paths may lead so now for real this time
congratulations class of 2023 we did it
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
to break
[Music]
memories
on Earth
Maybe
these words
[Music]
[Applause]
grandchilders
hello
thank you so much for coming to all our
senior events
and we hope you had a chance to dance a
little bit
and thank you to 88 of you who actually
read our emails
and this concludes our class a ceremony
we look forward to seeing you tomorrow
at commencement and at our 5
[Music]
. goodbye
[Applause]
thank you
foreign